du paysage de sully-sur-loire chacun
retient le château et la loire la ville
semble effacée neutre pourtant elle
porte un projet fort celui de la
reconstruction de l'après-guerre
olivier morin libraire est un historien
local doué il accompagne aujourd'hui
christelle chercheuse et benoît
urbanisme ils travaillent ensemble pour
une exposition à venir sur la
reconstruction région sans pour le
moment
il s'informe de l'histoire de suivi a
été élargi donc on a réoccupé les
boulevards la poste se trouver là ici la
remontons le cours du temps sully subira
par deux fois une destruction quasi
totale de son centre-ville
le 18 juin 1940 alors que le général de
gaulle lance son appel
l'aviation allemande bombardent la ville
en représailles de la destruction du
pont par les français effet collatéral
la ville s'enflamme comme il y avait
beaucoup de structures de bois à
l'intérieur c'est quand même une ville
ancienne avec des maisons en pans de
bois où beaucoup de bois à l'intérieur
la vie à brûler toute seule elle s'est
consumé au fil des jours et cinq jours
après on n'allait pas au delà des
boulevards le centre ville était trop
chaud la ville ayant été évacués
les gens quand ils sont revenus en ville
ils ont vu des ruines quand on arrivait
devant sa maison il n'y avait plus rien
les habitants ce relogement aux
alentours dans des baraquements et
commenceront le déblaiement un projet de
reconstruction s'élabore mais la ville
subit une deuxième destruction 6 juillet
1944 les forces alliées pilonnent le
pont à peine reconstruit sully une
seconde fois en feu est détruite à 70%
les habitants devront attendre la fin de
la guerre pour envisager la
reconstruction
avait un ministère et mary le ministère
de la reconstruction et de l'urbanisme
donc il était question de mandaté un
architecte et un urbaniste en chef qui
lui faisait un plan de la ville et donc
il définissait la morphologie urbaine
donc les auteurs du bâti la construction
sur plan donc le recul sur la voirie
l'épaisseur ce genre de choses
l'urbanisme de l'époque se veut avant
gardiste il prend en compte les nouveaux
besoins comme la circulation automobile
ou le réseau électrique urbain le modèle
d'habitat choisi est assez dense en ile
au bâti autour des espaces verts passage
porsche jardiner privé en arrière courts
et en façade
beaucoup de commerces le paysage de la
ville se recréer ils échappent à la
volonté de faire à l'identique comme
pour effacer le traumatisme de la guerre
on a tendance à parler notamment pour le
val de loire on a tendance à dire que
voilà on a refait à l'identique
non c'est pas vrai du tout c'est pas du
tout refait à l'identique mais par
contre effectivement il ya un esprit une
certaine homogénéité
malgré la diversité qui ressort en tout
cas de tout ça il ya une forme de plan
d'ensemble si on peut dire comme ça qui
est qu'ils aient pensé qui est imaginée
et qui est censé redonner la main de la
ville antérieur et en même temps tout en
la modernisant
l' architecture choisi ce doigt d'allier
modernité esthétique tout en répondant à
l'urgence du relogement des techniques
de préfabrication et de série sont
employés des matériaux locaux utilisés
comme la brique économique et donnent
une couleur locale
si l'ensemble est homogène l'architecte
et les bâtisseurs ont su jouer de
différence pour garder une âme a suivi
plan de reconstruction de sully les
pensées dès 1940 avec une certaine
homogénéité d'ensemble un esprit
d'ensemble même si y'a quand même à
l'intérieur de ça une certaine variété
mais il ya des éléments qui reviennent
et des éléments qui diffèrent et des
éléments de diversité qui font que
l'oeil est attiré ou pas et va nous
intrigue et il va y avoir des effets de
surprise que l'on appelle le pittoresque
et ça ça peut être effectivement tout à
fait intéressant et en même temps ça
s'insère dans un ensemble le patrimoine
bâti de la reconstruction n'est pas
classé pourtant sully perdrait de son
caractère si demain chacun le modifier à
sa façon l'objectif du projet
d'exposition sur la reconstruction et de
permettre un regard différent sur la
ville de donner des clés de
compréhension de son histoire afin que
chacun se sente investi dans son paysage
quotidien